yeah you know what welcome to this video
oh the Obama variation yeah that's not a
bad okay yeah I think I take hers yeah
it's been a six i defied is something
that you really have to and any travel
the radar night a success quite often
not a good reply see going for longer
shots maybe will be a sharp game if you
canceled strong I thought quite clear
how he covers the form in with other
moves own make sense so just development
I just keep the king in the middle for
moment I mean okay the look on age eight
is not doing anything but the rest of my
father's I mean the C file I have some
ideas myself not like he's the only one
and being able to play aggressive rules
so let's get the Queen near the action
please look at this and out this is what
the lower term okay um so especially
before a movie or not
[Music]
[Music]
nice before that's just a 3m vs this is
no serious again I don't want to play a
defensive move that looks really a lot
and maybe I can do this come on let's
play this
I met still play g6 know okay so i was
thinking light e7 to lend some cover to
g6 which is a defensive move which I did
not want to apply I know what I think it
might be wise to do on the other hand if
you place if he attacks my bishop now
where do I put it ah I totally did not
see that that my bishop has no squares
it has zero squares v6 is covered but he
might be too much focused on the Queen I
on the Kings side to notice who I had
absolutely no square a3 a queen a 4
which is very lucky but c3 I don't have
a square yeah tween 80 for his God be
three oh my god
I totally won the bet Queen a 4 p-3 no
trickery absolutely no trickery it was
pretty bad amazing magic plundered the
peace
ok skin condition is very little bit
shaky at little bit but he's got all
those pieces near right so he will be
certainly able to defend it and then
what ok I wasn't quite necessary yes but
I can take f3 here or maybe I have
something else nite aid for mmm maybe
but if a tick there this is not not so
clear right in this situation if he
takes them I'm getting a really nice 925
[Music]
two points I have ok this is not going
to stand up hold up to real professional
analysis with it but it is the practical
practically speaking not bad at all ok
no I have to bring the other look in as
well
now watch coordination has been great
them this is in fact not easy to play
for him at all night yes hehe i thought
this won t three is a nice-looking
square ok now 94 maybe is good for
having possible taking this porn default
Wow now he's trying for miracle moose
but I can take care for a chance check
check check
we've got this one coming up I extremely
lucky game I mean okay I was complete
Canadian completely lost of course that
i blundered a blunder the full piece in
the skin really are showing again and
better lucky than good he has the jew
baba opening here with the 93 Bishop f4
this is a really really okay variation
there's nothing wrong with it at all it
leads to complicated positions I am I
think this is a decent reply for black
but as you can see I mean like a six
this is not refuting hits the white the
white set up when you cannot do it
anyway with I'm just saying and this is
what I came up with after looking for an
antidote and now I think again black is
okay yeah but it's it's just complicated
and double edged you know with g-form I
probably um must improve somewhere here
it should be six what the engine is
currently suggesting that certainly
possible this one yeah and probably I
have to this already looks wrong but
that he gets an aged five that already
put me into some discomfort because g6
is currently threatening him he's got
the screen on f3 which covers oooook so
if i play let's save this move is
playing g6 and i have no okay I have
nothing to avoid the six scenario the
computer also doesn't find anything good
there should be seven great great move
by the engine yeah it'd be better than
this one Jim what is funny is that after
this the engine gives bishop age three
and not even be three I have this one
and using a pc haha that's interesting i
didn't see this resource this is the
point okay and then i should have played
it i mean okay it's clear that i'm in
bad shape but I'm see I'm saving the
piece at least wow that's really it can
put position okay and I went here okay
it takes it of course and he can
probably play like King a one and that
it was entirely unnecessary to to allow
the computer store things while is
completely winning that is probably true
well after rupees ring may I have no
serious compensation but here things are
not so easy for human players well the
thing is that white position is still
having active potential of course but he
has a completely wrecked structure the
double porn isolated pawns and those are
also not covering each other and this is
one of those cases where the looseness
of the position is difficult for a human
player to handle yeah I already was
quite optimistic that i would have some
chances I know it sounds a bit weird I'm
still a piece down for porn but it's not
easy for white to keep all those balls
in there i will definitely lose back up
or at least and so yeah here he gives me
this d 5 square and I get they easily
pawn and then now I'm kind of catching
up and then
engine already thinks that this is a
decent position for black some water it
might still be that you that you would
use against the kikuna yes but for a
human or a human clay and i think i
would prefer black by a mile it's just
easier to her to play and he came up
pretty quickly with this with this
blunder by now is is a bit uncomfortable
ready already am i get this i mean and
i'm better the engine might say equal
it's just so much easier for black to
play in a blitz game ok guys thanks for
watching